whoa nakedness can anyone tell my ABS
though yeah
battle ax and Val leaving little to the
imagination or I don't know maybe a lot
we don't really know well next time of
course finally one dancing last night
after 14 attempts at Roxy you infected I
was that everybody was so happy form and
they had a lot to say about those hats
but then max broke my heart please tell
us you're coming back to Dancing with
the Stars I don't think so
really why not ah this is exhausting it
has nothing to do with the wind it's
exhausting if he's for real I'm crushed
at least this got me smiling again
[Music]
this is the best video I've ever seen
first of all why was this out we have
friends in high places how long is this
video I want to see what's behind a hat
kick in the leg my eyes are blinded oh
[Music]
my god it's never-ending you're blushing
you're red I cannot believe that they
have with some video oh people calm
definitely has that and more here's the
final shot in the magazine on Stan's
Friday
we even got Dancing's shirtless Bros in
the hot seat first question who would
you bring home to mom and dad you'd be
kicked out of the first five minutes I
would like to be put on the record in
saying that moms love me and
grandparents dads fascinated by me and
who wears the bigger hat
[Music]
you